coveted vaccine booster shots are now
available for nearly 100 million
americans cdc director dr rochelle
wolenski backed an advisory panel's
recommendation to authorize moderna and
johnson and johnson boosters anyone 18
and older who received the j j vaccine
can now get a booster two months after
their initial shot those who received
the moderna vaccine at least six months
ago can get a booster shot if they're 65
and up or at high risk of infection
the cdc also said it is okay to mix and
match different vaccines dr rochelle
wallenski joins us now from atlanta
where the cdc is headquartered dr
wolenski good morning to you
good morning big day
glad to have you here uh big day for for
booster shot news i want to ask you
about the rollout what it will look like
and also if you could clarify uh when
the cdc authorizes something does that
mean it's also recommended in other
words you can get a booster should you
good morning yeah just i want to
articulate what an important next step
this is for our booster plan because we
now have a plan for boosters for all
three of our cova 19 vaccines you
outline the eligibility for
recipients the same as pfizer if you've
more than six months out of your last
shot and you're over the age of 65 or
high risk from underlying conditions or
by virtue of where you live or work and
also for fisa recipients the 15 million
pfizer recipients
they have are eligible for a booster if
they got their last dose if they got
their only dose more than two months ago
and then of course this important issue
of mix and match some people may prefer
to get the vaccine that they got
initially and and did really well with
others now may prefer to get another
vaccine and the cdc now allows for that
mix and match option um we have distinct
recommendations um we do recommend that
you do get your booster if you're
received the johnson and johnson vaccine
or if you have if you're over 65 and you
receive the modern advisor vaccine or if
you have underlying medical conditions
and you're over 50 we make you eligible
to receive a booster by virtue of where
you live or work so there are some some
subtleties as to whether we highly
recommend it or we just say eligibility
um but but all of those populations are
now eligible
got it doctor one of the subtleties is
uh the definition of a high risk setting
so the boosters are approved for people
in a high risk setting what is such a
setting
so high-risk settings
really do consider where you live and
where you work so if you are working in
a front line capacity a grocery store
worker a police officer health care
worker or if you live in a homeless
shelter or prison setting
those are the kinds of settings and we
have a whole list of those settings on
our cdc website
looking ahead
to november when we could see an
approval for vaccines the initial round
for kids as young as 5 5 to 11.
looking at some polls parents seem to be
making a different calculation than they
did for themselves when they think about
their kids and i think that's probably
because kids seem to be less susceptible
to severe illness
speaking to parents and getting ahead of
the approval here but speaking to
parents who are skeptical what should
they know about that calculation when it
comes to vaccinating their younger kids
first of all i just want to say how
wonderful it will be
when and if we have fda authorization
and cdc recommendations for vaccines for
children between the ages of 5 to 11.
we have recent data that demonstrates
that children with a delta variant are
just as likely to
get sick or get infected with delta
although they may be less likely to get
have severe symptoms we are still seeing
a lot of hospitalizations with the delta
variant and children and
when and if we have this authorization
and recommendations we will be talking
to parents about the importance of
pediatric vaccination i do want to say
that the
parents many parents in surveys are
really really excited to be able to get
their kids vaccinated and we have seen
over time comfort with vaccines with
more and more rollout we saw that with
adults we anticipate we will see that
increased uptake with children as well
all right booster shots overall now
available to nearly 100 million
americans a big day dr rashel walinski
thank you for walking us through it
thank you so much and for those 63
million who haven't yet been vaccinated
please go get your vaccine
no better time than the present all
right thank you